so we'll go to our next speaker who has
citizenship in the United States Canada
and Ireland so when the zombie
apocalypse H happens he has
options no not an option I have other
three passports oh what do you got oh I
I have United States Moldova and Romania
oh three options also who's going to
survive the zombie apocalypse we'll find
out either you or Malcolm please come to
the stage good afternoon uh talk about a
hard act to
follow good grief wasn't that
awesome I want to go androll in
something I I don't I don't even know
what I want to enroll in I just want to
make a difference Police Academy there
you go okay all right all right um hi
I'm Malcolm I'm the head of data
strategy with prophecy software I need
to make a few disclaimers and a few
apologies and
Advance first I am 95% confident that
the eggs I had this morning at the
Hilton Garden in ebore city were
toxic I feel horrible so please forgive
me but The Show Must Go must go on if I
Dart off uh it's it's because the eggs
are making a
return uh thank
you thank you because I don't feel great
uh second disclaimer and apology I don't
know python or R neither
Mi all right um I don't know python or R
and I was watching the presentations
this morning from from Jared and Joe I
was like you might as well be speaking
swah and every time that he said there
something for dummies I'm like here
comes the bit for me and then no it
wasn't about that it was about dummy
data um but I do know that he had
parameter Miss build on every
slide just saying uh so I'm here to talk
about MDM Master d management and I was
talking earlier with with some folks I
had a this presentation is is designed
for an hour I'm going to cut it way down
we're going to we're going to take just
the a bridged version here but I was
talking to others earlier and this is
before I felt like I was going to
literally die um and saying you know hey
I'm here to talk about MDM well what's
MDM I like oh okay oops all right uh
maybe I need to change the presentation
and uh talking about kind of like who I
am and where I come from and I'm well
I'm an exg Gartner analyst because I am
I was at Gartner and and they're like
What's
Gard um I'm like okay all right uh
credibility uh low um and uh so so this
is going to be an a bridge version uh I
talk about this stuff day in and day out
I have been uh a CIO I have run a
product organization I've been an
analyst I've been a consultant I've
written these things called Magic
quadrants in case that actually right on
brother one one one for the magic
quadrant um
so I'm I'm going to share some
information today about something called
MDM Master data management what is MDM
it's basically three things it's a
discipline that is technology
driven um two it is
about a common governance approach to
number three shared data okay so shared
data customers assets locations
employees Parts material the data that
is shared widely across the
organization which naturally ends up
getting highly replicated there's
different governance policies for it
data sitting in a CRM system is
drastically different than data sitting
in an Erp system even though it's
representing the exact same thing MDM is
designed to
solve this problem Acme Acme Inc Acme Co
Acme LLC is that one thing or is that
four things they all have different
Source IDs you pull that into an
analytics layer and you'd think that's
four things because it's got four Source
IDs and you're going to naturally trust
that the business people know exactly
what they're doing to create this
data so the problem that MDM solves is
one is this one thing or is it four
things so it does that using business
rules governance policies that are
created in collaboration between
business folks and it folks this is
another way another way of saying this
Francy way of saying it is something
called entity resolution you may have
done this or maybe you've even created
your own R python to do entity
resolution that's an MDM is quite good
at the second thing is if it is one
thing then how do we at least link them
together under some common ID or maybe
even physically merge them together
these are what we call two different
styles of MDM analytical versus
operational MDM systems sit between MDM
it's basically a data Hub right we take
little Snippets little chunks of data
out of source systems we replicate yes
we replicate some of the data and put it
into its own Standalone Hub and it
applied these common business rules to
it that's what MDM is it sits between
Source systems and the analytical
platforms that y all run and manage day
in and day out so we Square on what MDM
is all right
cool I'm going to talk about the future
this presentation is was kind of
designed for folks that that already
know what MDM is and live and breathe in
my space MDM provides something called
the single source of Truth and every
time that I use the phrase single source
of Truth people are like that's didn't
we figure that out 10 years ago didn't
we didn't snowflake figure fix that
didn't data virtualization fix that
didn't Big Data fix all of that didn't
all of these other things fix that no it
didn't it's still a
problem it is still a massive problem
and I'm sure you're dealing with it day
in and day out is MDM still relevant yes
it most certainly is because
this currently feeling like crap dude
says it is so I said that MDM is
transitioned from a nice have to a must
have I said that in the last MDM magic
quadrant document for anybody who cares
what that is but I helped write it uh
that's me in my business attire I live
in Melbourne Florida directly across the
peninsula uh if you ever want to come
and watch rockets take off let me know
we can catch a rocket launch in the
evening and watch some turtles in the
morning anywho MDM is still relevant
it's not going anywhere what does the
future of this single source of Truth
look like well it looks kind of like
this this is the future of all dat what
we call data management applications so
data quality data governance data
integration Master data management is
all on this path to go from Human driven
to machine driven we're somewhere over
here we're somewhere over
here we're going to move and we already
have to machine assistant we call this
augmentation right this is the
application of AI ml graph other things
to do start automating some of the
decisions we make about how we manage
data start automating things like data
quality Rules start automating things
like the entity resolution that I was
talking about letting the robots start
to decide some of the governance
policies for the data we use day in and
day out I actually fully believe and I'm
fully confident that data governance can
largely be
automated can largely be automated and
that's the path that we are on from
people figuring out what's Master Data
customer outside employee location how
do I model that what are the attributes
that Define a customer right
historically people have figure that
stuff
out and in the future it's all going to
be machines because we know we'll look
at it we'll figure out what data is used
widely what data is shared widely what
data appears across all these different
applications that needs common business
rules applied to it so this is the this
is where we are going this could be MDM
this could be data quality data
governance data integration doesn't
matter we are on a road to Automation
and I think it's a good thing MDM is
inherently about the application of
consistent business rules the
application of consistent governance
policies how do I Define a customer what
are the attributes of a customer when is
it unique these are governance policies
these are rules if we can use the
internet to train llms we can certainly
use our own data so I see the evolution
of kind of smaller learning language
models right that are deployed
specifically
against internal data sets where we are
trying to solve and model specific
business processes quote to cash peur to
pay these are all in my estimation these
are all essentially languages that can
all be modeled that can all be modeled
and where the nuances between maybe a
customer versus an account is like are
those the same
thing the AI enabled future we will have
will we'll know that these are the same
thing of course they're the same thing
of course they're the same thing really
where we're going is something what
people like me call a data fabric you
may have heard of a data fabric maybe
you haven't but a data fabric is to me
is a world where data
itself data informs its classification
and use so instead of people doing it
instead of people defining the
governance policy the data itself will
Define its own governance
policies this is really the vision of a
data fabricant sitting right in here
something called MDM this is what this
is a Gartner graph so thank you to my
ex-employer for those who know what
Gartner is um a Knowledge Graph enrich
with semantics MD MDM is a
turbocharged very powerful semantic
layer but if you've heard of a semantic
layer there there is an there is a
software branch called semantic layer
they link things out a schema level at a
table level MDM links things at a at a
record level or field level object
level business rules and far more
flexibility than what you can do and
what you can't
do but the data fabric is a world where
data kind of informs its own use and its
own
classification to do that we have to do
something called activating the metadata
this is this is this is a a business
person's way of saying deep analysis of
met lot of being run against metadata so
that we know we know when transactions
are successful or they're not
successful right we can know when data
quality is high or when data quality is
fit for purpose because we will know
when transactions succeed or when maybe
they slow down in that quote toach
process maybe something takes three days
when it should have taken two days or
vice versa maybe that's an indicator of
low data
quality we'll know because we're running
graphs against massive troves of
transactional data to tell us when
things are working correctly or when
they're not working correctly the data
will tell
us so I'm not going to go into each of
these in more detail if we want to talk
about um what what I would call critical
capabilities of future
MDM um I won't go into detail but
there's a few things that are kind of
interesting historically MDM required a
lot of data
replication right we would replicate
customer records out of multiple Source
systems and put them into a hub and then
apply a bunch of business rules to them
in the future we will match data we will
do that entity resolution to data where
it sits we won't actually have to
replicate the
data um we're doing we were moving
towards something called adaptive
governance what that really means is
that context matters historically it was
about coming up with a single set of
business rules the one source of Truth
one definition of customer to rule them
all when in reality we know that the way
marketing defines a customer is
different than the way Finance defines a
customer this to be true that's what's
meant by adaptive governance you've got
multiple business
rules same thing could be said for data
quality you could have adaptive data
quality where you've got different
quality standards based on how the data
is actually used in an
organization that's hard the reason why
that's hard is because for for
companies right having one set of
business rules is hard enough what we're
talking about here is n sets of business
rules for Quality accuracy consistency
that's going to be really hard but
thankfully that's where AI comes in
we're going to use AI to start
automating some of these things and at
the beginning augmenting them because
it's hard enough maybe you've been in
that meeting where it's like hey we're
going to do a tiger team and working our
customer
definition and bu bring everybody into a
table and start talking about you know
how do we Define customer and finance
says one thing and accounting says and
and marketing says another and then it's
one of the these well I'm right no I'm
right no I'm right no I'm right they're
both
right that's what being adaptive is from
a governance perspective um MDM will tie
tightly into Data cataloges data
cataloges are kind of the new black out
there like if you go to an industry
conference everybody's trying to sell
you a data catalog because who doesn't
want to do an inventory of their
data um
blockchain yes I said it out
loud blockchain is not dead I'm going to
talk in a little bit because I've got
six minutes left about really one one of
the most exciting things I find in the
in the future of MDM which is
intercompany data
sharing right so today in essence what
MDM is is breaking silos Silo Silo Silo
I'm going to break them and we do that
because we realize economies of scale we
we we realize efficiencies that aren't
there when data is siloed if you view a
company as a silo and start breaking
silos across companies there's a lot of
goodness there and the reason why we're
going to do this is because we don't
want to be caught flat-footed the next
time a ship gets stuck in the Suez Canal
or the next time there are some other
massive disruptions somewhere right or
or supply chain interruptions and on and
on companies are going to start sharing
data in more widespread ways than they
ever have before I think blockchain is
going to be very very helpful for that
because it's actually going to create an
incentive layer for shared
governance for shared business rules
today the problem a lot of companies
aren't really sharing data because they
don't it's it's hard to for everybody to
agree on some of these common business
rules some of the governance policies
needed to create a shared data
ecosystem maybe even something data as a
service or governance as a service but I
think blockchain will help with that
because it'll create an incentive layer
multi-dimensional hierarchies today our
hierarchies within MDM systems is
another thing they do is they manage
hierarchies relationships between
customers or suppliers or assets they're
going to be multi-dimensional you've
already seen that today with some of the
graphs and some of the visualizations of
graph and of course data stewardship
we're going to we're going to automate
the people that are manually reviewing
Acme and Acme Inc today often people are
doing that so I won't go through each of
these in
detail um in my last five
minutes is it an awesome that like we
can have ai generate what otherwise
would be a massive copyright
violation that's not Buzz Light you're
that's somebody who looks just like him
in another version of this I've got Mel
Gibson's like the Braveheart it's like
that's not Mel Gibson it's somebody that
just
looks um anyway
um a hype cycle here um kind of metaphor
but things that I see in in my world
trending up trending down going away I
won't go through each of these there's a
few things product management data
management is kind of on the upswing and
I think that's really good thing I'm
excited about the application of product
management into data management
historically we've been pretty insular
we've talked about stakeholders and
users we never really talk about
customers and I think we need to talk
more about customers we need to treat
our internal users as actual custom and
product managers going to help with that
I I think we are finally going to start
doing a little more ROI analysis on some
of the products that we built some of
the data products we built um I already
mentioned about data sharing context
drives truth so so the truth is is
interesting um the notion of Truth is
context bound within every one context
there's multiple contexts in the
organization but within each context
there are still only one version of the
truth so yes we can check and say there
is no such thing as a single version of
the truth because marketing looks at the
world different than Finance looks at
the world but within each of those
various there is only one version of the
truth including the seite if your CEO
asks how many customers do we have
there's only one answer to that don't be
that person in the meeting that says
well depends who's asking because I have
been it doesn't doesn't bode well for
your for your tenure in the data and
analytics
World um trending down there's a few
things ah data literacy this is this one
I've got a problem with data literacy
I've got a huge problem with it um I I I
view it to be a bit of a toxic
Force um the reason why is because if
I'm a if I'm a product person if I'm
building a widget right and everybody
hates the widget they don't use it the
adoptions low they complain about it um
they they don't trust
it right is is is the problem the skill
of the user or is the problem the
widget the problem is the widget widget
data literacy assumes that our end users
don't get value out of the data we
provide because their skills are lacking
somehow some
way that may be the case but we need to
look inside before we look outside we
need to look at what we're doing we need
to look at the data we provide we need
to look at its accuracy its consistency
its trust
trustworthiness before we start saying
well I think you need some
training you need to go maybe you do
need to learn python or R I don't know I
I don't but
uh owners that just cracks me up data
owners I am the owner of
data try having that conversation with
your Chief Revenue officer on day
one right sit down and say hey yeah yeah
I'm you know I'm in the data and
analytics team and I am now the owner of
customer data I own your customer data
Chief Revenue officer good luck with
that
conversation nobody owns data we all own
data we all own it anyway separate
conversation I know this this some of
these things are heretical because they
kind of challenge dhma da
ma I happy to connect offline to go into
more detail a lot of this
stuff I would look forward to a world
where we are more customer-driven this
is writ larger than the data thater
Space by the way I challenge the notion
of being data
first be customer first or as Brett said
outcome first work backwards from the
outcome it's not about the data it's
about business
value when I was a g analy I used to
talk to people so often about you know
how are you going about solving your
problem well I'm going to go inventory
all my data and I profile it I'm going
to gloss read it I'm
gonna like time out why don't you go
figure out what the problem is first
before you go start with inventories I
can keep going through but I I I I
really see that Chief date officers at a
bit of an inflection point a lot of
companies are frustrated with a lack of
progress from a chief chief data officer
and I think because there's too much
stuff on the left hand side and we need
more stuff on the right hand
side oh I mentioned data sharing I also
happen to think we've got a massive well
I don't happen to think it's a fact we
got a massive data hoarding
problem depending on who you ask 50 to
80% of data in data centers is dark just
sitting there collecting digital
dust also happens that the data center
industry produces more Greenhouse gas
than the airline
industry think about that one we've got
we us have got trows of data sitting
there collecting dust and it's actually
negatively impacting the the environment
if we start sharing data more maybe we
can
lessen our footprint on the environment
lastly governance from Rules from rural
management B shouts to more exception
management this is where I see I see
things heading r large in data and
Analytics be driven by the exceptions
instead of driven from the bottom up by
rules I'm out
of um connect with me please connect
with me on LinkedIn that's that's
me I'm very active on LinkedIn I'm
posting best practices insights advice
every day I've got a podcast called the
CDI matters podcast I've got all sorts
of stuff and I talk I'm I'm like I
literally travel the world talking so I
can do better than I did today under my
my my toxic egg fog
um but it's been my pleasure to be here
so nice to meet everybody my apologies
I'm I'm not networking more because I I
I really do feel like crap but thanks
for being here
today